what other soundtracks are [ __ ] great
what's your top five soundtracks
honestly i just think i really think
eight miles is the best one ever really
yeah that's this is a dope soundtrack i
think that was the last
of the good soundtracks i think eight
mile had the best eminem ever
and to me if you have three records on
there that are the best eminem that
exists
and he's one of the greatest of all time
yeah absolutely and then there was there
the best
you get you better love me [ __ ] [ __ ] 50
obi wan
was on that too that's four minutes yeah
that's a fire it was the jay z's eyes on
that freeway one
eight miles and running wasn't that jay
and free i know they were you know that
wank still was on there yeah you're
right that's a fire soundtrack
nutty professor was a fire soundtrack
nutty professor had the eminem red man
yeah
yeah and it had [ __ ] uh foxy [ __ ]
yeah man [ __ ] that nutty nerdy professor
was crazy
above the rim was a fire one was great
colors was crazy um
friday
friday friday's number two for me
shots the uh the keep the head ringing
keep that yeah the doctor drake keep
your head oh you know which one was hard
was bullworth
yes
that and they had the uh there was an ll
cool j record on this yeah it's crazy
footwork was fire
i liked um i wasn't mad at the 50 cent
uh movie for soundtrack
the movie was terrible but
you didn't like that yeah i mean i
didn't love it i feel like it was uh i
didn't
it's kind of was like the same thing as
eminem's right just as i said i also
didn't love eight mile so you know i
like i think it was cool nah i think i
was fine shout out to brittany murphy
yeah no no the battle scenes are amazing
yeah that's just crazy okay i have a
belly poster behind you and i always say
that belly that's a fire sound crazy
that's one that might be number one the
gangstar militia remix with dub c's on
there that
uh uh here comes the boom here comes the
boom
pawn dmx yeah yeah you might be right
it's up there half a mil mm-hmm
there was some [ __ ] on there um they had
the locks with made men they had brown
not no devil in there
and a dress or something d'angelo's pie
yeah they had the nas
uh
metaman and dmx joint great soundtrack
yeah that's why is it the best worst
movie of all time
you think belly's a bad movie i think
it's a great bad movie yeah yeah
i could agree on that because growing up
i just thought it was a great movie yeah
and then once i started watching like a
lot of movies yeah
and then i tried to re-watch belly like
again like at like 24 25 i was like
you know wasn't as good as i remember it
was just a great like looking movie and
it had my favorite rappers in it exactly
so it was [ __ ] amazing there was like
moments like in the beginning where they
go into the [ __ ] bathroom before the
guns out shoot up the lady in the club
and then [ __ ] uh with dmx is [ __ ]
dressed like a homeless guy yeah yeah it
had nothing to do with nothing
just random acts of violence the dude's
eating the [ __ ] the the fruit glizzy
the banana and he's like oh yeah yeah we
gotta drop the diamonds i don't like
this [ __ ]
that's like going on a uh uh like a
great like a six flags when you're a kid
like yo this place is huge and then you
go there as an adult and like it's not
that big over here i'm saying this is
kind of small got like [ __ ] four rods